so alright alright so we are live we are
both laugh the last word or loaded
shooters or the eat boxes what is going
on sir oh it's been a fun week oh yeah
there is there was no how do you say
Bungie did what they do best and they
drop some stuff we've got so we've got a
quest to talk about we've got a table to
talk about we've got a shift in momentum
from another developer working on
division action and then just a quick
set recap recap of the status of anthem
at the end for a little uh a little
somber moment there in the end it's
gonna be it's gonna be chilling for a
bit but yeah what you been doing I'll
let you start first sir Haven Oh busy
week but um you know try to sneak some
destiny in unfortunately I did not get a
chance to partake in the glory that we
shall talk about later
yeah but I'm pleasantly surprised just
to see just to see when the game does
right yes a but but when when Bungie
does right there and these are the
things without talking about like it's
so capable you know there and when I see
stuff like this it just it just
reaffirms my conviction like you know
they did when they do something right
how great the community is how you see
people come together I've seen the
tweets I've seen you know people doing
getting on there like little messages
scavenger hunts you know does it and
like it's fun it's fun to see and I'd
like to see the community like that but
ya got players a little play a little
bit but um not bad I'll let you get into
that when we get to it and um yeah
that's pretty much it man but uh what we
got on tap today man so first thing that
happened so of course on Tuesday I'll be
like waiting to log in doing the weekly
reset and people didn't people caught it
and I didn't even notice cuz I'm sitting
there like making my video and I'm
watching twitch and or I'm watching
Twitter go like nuts so basically what
happened is like normally the flashpoint
will come out and I'll have its
adventure sitting right next to it
mm-hmm
and it's like okay so those are cool
chillin and then after a little bit
I didn't know how long it was because as
I said I was doing my like Tuesday thing
and then it the adventure switched over
to another planet so people just lost
their mind because they're like alright
something's up we got this like downtime
the exact and this was this is a funny
thing I had a chance to play with
somebody won't say who but I was just
like playing with them and I ain't
dropping trou no but I was like it was a
serious question I think we had talked
about it before cuz we were wondering is
árboles the exotic quest for everybody
and I was quietly told no just was like
was it the exotic questions like no it's
not a quest it was like well okay and
that's like that was it like they
weren't gonna they were just like it's
not a quest and I was like alright so
mm-hm
and then this and then literally it was
not that long it's like three days and I
was like oh and then this happened I was
like ah and people just started losing
their mind so spoiler alert if you guys
don't know what the heck is going on in
a few seconds here but basically three
two one outbreak prime is back in dusty
but it is now called outbreak perfected
so it looks really nice it's a fun gun
to use but the question is interesting
my stream would know I did not look up
any of the nodes I figured them out now
I had a little like some guidance in
places definitely needed to get a little
help some hot and cold on you know on
stray and being like hey am I looking in
the right place cuz man some of these
little nodes dude yeah a real minuscule
they yeah they're not the biggest then
there's a couple and it was just like in
the weirdest lake up in this little
black box in here and I was like because
there's no sound effect there is nothing
until you see nothing yep so what are
you yeah - no no just live those like
the two on the to unnecessary probably
the hardest there's one that I was like
because one of the clues is like you
know six heads on spikes tripped or
whatever it I was like okay so I'm
running around in lost sector figured
out the clue what I think it is then I
go in there and I'm standing by this
thing and look it is like six goals on a
spy
and I'm like okay where the hell
apparently there's like if so I got all
fixated on that one then like walking
around they're like they're just like
you know like cold icicle called him
like we'll crap with it then I go
wandering around there's two more sets
of these things in the same in the same
law sector I'm like awesome
so I finally found the right one there
but yeah it took me a while my stream I
was like alright no spoilers guys like
they could give me like minor like you
kept it hard and fast with this ghost
boy yeah I told my stream I was like
that was I'd literally changed chat
rules that day I was like no spoilers
today so try to figure it out a lot
because we don't get these that often we
really don't this man really immerses
himself
I got a respect you for me I had time I
had fun so I was like alright we gonna
do this real we can do it right so it's
kinda and it was like I'm not gonna be
the first one to do it I like literally
it was like oh what's going on and dad
was like in the mission already was like
fine so yeah but I mean yeah node one I
thought will earn node I was like I was
even recording the first section on my
videos like alright so we're doing node
2 it ended up being node 1 so I like had
the clues backwards oh wow yeah so I
picked up was like alright now I really
don't understand what I just did so
there's some fun puzzles they are
specific things like I had to Google
like lost sector boss names oh yeah cuz
there's like or lost sector names and
there's certain ones that I'm like
alright so there's like one word in here
that makes this sense okay there's like
there's one word here that's weeks to
this one so there's all these little
bits and pieces that will technically
steer you but then when you get in there
you could walk over it like four times
and miss it which I did you miss out
yeah it's right minuscule very minuscule
got him it I gave you credit my leg you
was on you got she's Sherlock Holmes on
he was doing detective work a little
guidance on a couple of us yeah as like
people were like hot cold icicle brain
and arctica and we're frozen so like
there were times I was failing pretty
miserably so yeah yeah Lou the nodes
were cool and then of course we knew
because I'd seen it as I said you find
all six nodes
and then the middle of this thing shows
rendezvous basically and it has this
just ridiculous block of text
it has technically 10 characters and I
wonder if that translates to rendezvous
[Music]
but who you end up finding is and what
starts all this all and this is what my
brother had the issue of it was like
playing during the day and I told him it
was like alright so there's a new quest
and he gets home like it's home like hey
try it then I go have dinner and come
back he's like dude I've been trying to
do this thing for like two hours why he
was he was trying everything he could
like get in there figure out what was
going on so basically what happens is
you can't start this quest you can't get
the transponder now it is unless you
beat enemy for my enemy you just have to
be at the mission right now yes certain
public has actually tested Omaha oh and
all the way through enemy enemy last
night on my hunter now I did not kill
the captain on my hunter okay I have my
warlock who hasn't done it either and I
want to test if I go in there blast the
warlock or black blast that blast both
of them because it's like him in the
night fighting and he's gonna Shoals in
the night doesn't it I'm like so if you
do kill him can you get to the door
yeah be introduced allude to sinister in
the chat today yeah once I would he
Marcus boarded me hey he was the one
yeah we were running together we got
them yeah we got the gun shows so a
salute continues though we got that and
then so yeah so as you go through you're
looking at this lake right you go
through and so my brother had this like
major issue so I finally had to have him
start the heroic adventure a point us in
the right place which I guess maybe he
could have just gone with on me me on
patrol too but I had to unlock the door
because I had done it in he hadn't hmm
that was a weird that's what the only
thing about this that I would say like
issues with and then they they had a
patch recently to fix some things that
were glitching out yeah yep that's my
video so yeah let's get to it
let's get to that let me ask you some
questions I was like I haven't gotten a
mission so yeah I asked about that okay
no no question the questions is alright
um you go start them you get to the
mission stuff like I got I got a couple
to
we're doing spoilers are we allowed to
talk about where we at with this right
now
no I already said okay wise what makes
enough so my question is as a warlock
who has PTSD foo jumping in in whisper
of worm-like I looked at videos whatever
than hunters here would be fine yeah it
look it look I felt when I watched it I
was like do this I felt good you know
say for what I saw that was the friend
of the second thing do they have ominous
annoying scary music and people talking
to you like how soul would talk to you
during the I hate again whisper I hate
okay what's the fire but a music we need
give me that um I mean it's like like
what it's a new tree I mean you're back
in this hour like an old tower so it's I
was actually ELISA I was specifically
trying to listen I went on one of my
solo like practice runs hymens all
loaded yet but that will have to happen
at some point
yeah the music just kind of ramped up
there's a couple points where it's like
oh crap no it's it's fitting I think
you'll like the track and I usually dig
the music I think you'll like the track
I don't know specifically how to
describe it not scary about like ominous
it's pretty quick it's pretty upbeat
yeah alright so upbeat
ah cuz again PTSD warlock here whisper
the worm tough jumps I'm in this dark
place so talking's very strong to me in
all the hunters you guys all ahead
flying and zipping around and I'm gonna
back with my flu and I'm feeling the
tension that I've seen the clock its
citizens laughing at me because I keep
dropping and making stupid mistakes but
it's not that okay okay so I got this
sorry I did a second question was if the
warlock was never hard to jump on
whisper as much as I ran that thing
because I could I needed in exotic pair
of boots to skip one part in the warlock
or one part of the jumping and what the
warlock I just literally landed it it
was like okay moving on okay so it's
like now you'll be fine I've watched
honestly most solos I watched just due
to the survivable nature and also it's
do or die
I'm Cara mostly solos I've seen are
running it with a warlock actually oh
cool cool cool I said now you start from
your experience and now you know you get
the mission you do the rendezvous in the
fall dope yeah like in the farm you go
back to the farm you go underneath the
big thing and it's pretty obviously
where's everybody at 14 named tiles are
sitting down below the building over
here look huh I wonder where to go all
the way oh all the blueberries I'm not
new berries no honestly it was one of
the funniest things I think I've seen
while playing during this mission and
this is like kind of want to bring back
it's like when bunchy does something
alright it will bring people back yeah
this is what I've been saying dude don't
you don't they do d3 right they'll bring
people back Oh what is that they should
do this we should take what we got
before and accept it we should keep it
we could make this working so hard and
we should interrupt them anyway but no
it was hilarious because everyone I saw
like those 20 people on the farm all had
freaking titles many of them were
ribbons bein a lot of them were high
level people who put in work and they're
like hey this is something new I gotta
get a jump on those were a lot of people
I saw I was like curse breakers lots of
ribbons Bane yeah there's a lot of
ribbons mate actually that I saw
specifically I was like so these are
your high end these are ones here so
that was cool
no Hawk oh happy that's guy mission
starts and you basically you're in
you're in the tower
you're Kennedy in the tower back in the
city the old one that got busted up and
there's a moment where you're about two
rooms to the second room of enemies in
and you realize you're standing on top
of flake no what would the little place
where like Abel Levante was and though
oh okay and like where your vaults
weren't you're like you realize that
it's where you walk in with Zavala and
he's like sitting there holding it down
in the first mission so they're using
like this old first first yeah yeah it
was uh so that was like I was looking
around was like oh we're so yeah so yeah
come on back to mission one of destiny
using that one well and then you start
working through I mean the enemies
there's a so many shields so many
shields there's questions what do I now
have are bolused buyers remorse but not
you can get it without what I know about
protests I've well yeah that's your own
fault what could I do II what is the it
good job you're not gonna solo this
thing your first time there's just run
with people you'll be fine
I didn't see one where somebody was
running for speed and they were using
the árboles to pick off other things
while other people who were doing other
stuff so I mean it does actually serve a
purpose because something like match
game isn't on and nullifying it so I
mean I saw you could have one person
around it for sure cuz I watched a video
people doing that it interests so I mean
it actually does have a decent use for
decent amount of ammo especially if
you've got reserves pop and shielded
guys in the face kind of getting a good
break on them extra damage like you mean
there's places where it would work
really well especially if you're like
hey I don't want to pop my heavy on
these servitors hey let me pop it once
with our bolused and then you can do
some extra damage people won't run it
with recluse like dude there's options
you don't have to what I mean just cuz
you felt like boycotting the game not to
get an exotic that's your own fault but
listen do you think how long that thing
actually took listen I've made my point
about protests to creat the PvP
community was very happy with me the
list is it there we go get it you'll
have to let me know when this thing
drops for you cuz it's gonna no I'm
gonna get it I'm definitely because
literally every week I watches our video
and then I go get what I need and then
if I have my 97 shards I use a faded
it's why I you know what motivated me
they're going they got no choice to give
it to me because all I got left
oh yeah they do no it's not innovated I
know but listen i'ma break it down I got
all I got left that I that I'm missing
is Phoenix protocol and um you know my
lord of wolves still ain't get that and
I'm saying maybe one of my hens dick now
I'm not gonna use fade it no more after
that so then it becomes orangey and the
way the algorithm algorithm works is yo
what you don't have we're gonna try to
give you more so I'm gonna get it so
stop it
continue check back in like six months
you'd be like man that arglist be like
things really hard to get nobody but so
that was your loadout what was to bring
me give me the mic
so honestly like first time I ran and I
ran like I was running hammerhead I ran
borealis and then just my go figure so
I'd borealis cuz there's a just so many
shield so many shields and then I was
using that to kind of mix it up and then
hammerhead was just still good machine
gun pumping out some damage really what
you're gonna do and it's honestly the
way I ended up running whisper later is
you have a lot of shields and for me as
a solo with a group if you're just like
I got these I got these I got these as
long as people can kind of run and stay
together you'll be okay
but as a solo what same thing I did for
whisper I had primer can primary ammo in
my energy slot that I could switch guns
out all the time be like okay i saw i
got like kindled orchid so i have okay
okay mom what the hell else was I using
you can either use trust or actually had
the oxygen sr3 so for solar and that
covered and then for our whatever you
put borealis away when he got hot and
heavy we're not when I was going trying
to go solo because boreal like it was
good and that was kind of one of those
things I'm still like debating on
because it's like we'll do oh and infuse
like three guns up yes I'm plenty of
shards but do I have enough of the crap
I mean boy al is still worried to have
course oh no I have cores like I've like
300 son course though how did you know
it's more like do I have like specific
700 items to infuse into like oh I
haven't yeah so I know I used like 21%
delirium at some point I was mixing it
up mommy said he did AAA
yeah so I mean there's options you just
have to be able to hit because it starts
the first rooms gonna be like the shanks
have void shields and then the captains
have our shields here like had two
shields and there's snipers like always
then you get two yeah Boyles just runs
IMO quick yeah absolutely
then the next room the shanks have Ark
shields there's major the big heavy
shanks with solar shields it's like okay
so you get to next room
you've got servitors with void shield so
it's like first looms are this like
quick rotation of all the shields you
have to have some way to combat them all
they make work and make it work shank
okay so honestly what a lot of people
will do you might have like a heavy
machine gunner for the first couple but
as soon as you start seeing the tanks
and later on towards the final boss
fight
whispers crucial really yep because the
distance you got a these so much common
accidents and again if you can hit a big
target in the face or in the tank leg
because there's two tanks in the final
room look for spawn about halfway
through what about what about what about
all good old reliable though I hear you
talk that done the Lord talk it's an
exam taking up a slide mmm it's like if
I have to sit around yeah so limit you
you're right you're right so basically
you going in you're gonna go yeah that's
I mean that's the same way I ran whisper
solo is the same thing is like I would
take I would take like a solar pulse
rifle I think is what I do switch over
to my arc bow or no void bow for the
middle part of whisper in the end I was
switch over like my misfit for all the
little stuff in the end so same
principle but like even the harder to an
extent so there's a lot more shields and
you've got a fight it's not like run
through a jumping puzzle and if I could
get through the jumping puzzle and
whisper in like four and a half minutes
I get to where I could do it close to
four or four and a half minutes like
head it down pretty packed this one you
have like a fight to get through yeah
and I've watched I did the jumping the
normal version of the jumping version
about six minutes 20 seconds is shows
kind of doing a run like but it took me
a while to solo kill the enemies but I
watched even like esoterics tune in like
about 6 minutes like that jumping pills
of the gift or is about you know 5:45
6:15 like I mean 30 seconds in there
two solid six minutes solid look it I
looked at the jumps they didn't look
difficult or something I wasn't capable
I just said man is up this is a long SEC
yeah it's a good solid six wait it was
when I watched it but I felt excited the
fan part look funny um that tell me
about that part where that wild
electricity is coming to get you and
that did that looked a lot concerned me
we have not talked about the terror that
is Trevor yeah
Trevor apparently by name since bunchy
tweeted out the TR e - r or TR three
whatever there is some Hilaire Bungie
tweeted or somebody tweeted a video like
this guy just like losing his mind
screaming like a little girl of this
thing like run and stuff like that so
basically you've got kind of and it
honestly reminds me of the movie Maze
Runner if anybody saw that because it
was funny on Mazer and are like wow - I
like we don't read a ton of books
together but it was a car trip and we
read them like we listen to the audio
books for those so in our mind when you
see Mazur at like before we saw Maze
Runner in our mind I was like alright
what is this crazy because it's like the
monsters out in the maze like what is
this gonna look like and it's like oh my
god and it sounds like you see the movie
but it's like it's again this thing just
with like mechanical arms and crazy face
just crazy thing that's just gonna
terrify the crap because it's like it's
awesome mmm
doh so that part is amazed where you
have to hit there's like four boxes take
a big square of a room divided into four
there's kind of a middle mini rectangle
in the middle for like kind of moving
around but then off of that rectangle on
the two sides on the left and two on the
right there's two squares that have
switches and you got to hit all four
over the whole time this crazy robots
doing laughs buying shoes yeah and he's
gonna go like off off to the side and
chase you down if you're in the switch
sometimes there's like shock walls that
are up like stopping you from moving so
like depending on timing
now you can solo run if you just drop
down and wait for him to pass underneath
you and go to the left you can get it
all I've sold it at this point but so
you have sold this off I haven't sold
the mission
sollozzo run I've got to get my enemy
clearing in the first part quicker so I
have more time to finish the end but
I've got the maze part pretty much solo
run but that premium backpack carry
ready to solo that work oh yeah I got a
ways I got a ways where I got confidence
you see honestly like if I got confident
off to do a solo and I could actually
squeeze it in in the full twenty minutes
which I see most people do a solo like
with less than 30 seconds to go it's
pretty tight nobody's just like blasting
the doors off of this thing but if you
had people with you helping to kill the
enemies in the beginning and then you
had the solo through the puzzle if you
knew you could finish the end having
people with you just to shoot stuff in
the face in the beginning would only
make it faster so that's actually a good
thing okay so I mean it's on it like so
you get through with the trevor part you
go through more jumping and waiting on
elevators and finding the right path and
then you get to the boss room and you
guys so boss room is crazy captain who's
got like an arching kind of grenade
launcher thing they're like slow travel
like throwing constantly not Molotov
cocktails cuz they don't explode but
like kind of arching little mini
explosions that fly at you slowly so
he's doing that the whole time soon as
you do damage to him there's like giant
servitors
yeah skull of dire ah hum car is just
crazy useful yeah crazy now you already
I'm sticking out I build know if you're
last year you better take Scott in there
so they smash the big servitors in the
face then you have a couple tanks that's
fun then you have shielded shanks of
each type that's fun on the sides there
arc in the back of the room from where
you spawn and behind you would be solar
in the front of the room would be void
and so those again you got to be able to
manage all three types of shields like
so that's something like both ends of it
- let me ask you - because all right
it's the warlocks out there I've got a
sick build right now with
Khatri ark we buffed arm stormcaller
like I'm like I'm soloing stuff with
that bill and the thing about it is um
but the way you're dizzy right you need
right yeah that the way you're
describing I need rain so it did so
basically what you're saying is it's not
gonna be like I'm overwhelmed with
groups in the immediate tight-knit
vicinity everybody's kind of distanced
out a little bit is that what's going on
yeah no you did - everything's too far
away so slow Slovo yeah I mean if your
warlock that if you got two warlock so
one can have a well irradiance now what
I didn't expect and I was like in the
moment
Marissa furiosa and the walking shield
as much crap that's flying at you I was
like we're gone hi it's super BEC hold
it up for a while super God Oh super
back so I was literally just like I was
taking ever the tanks like the tanks
were hitting my shield and just
refilling me and they were handling
everything both side and to the sides
and up front they just had the shield to
walk through couple boxes couple boxes
to peak between link peeking through and
then yeah it was Sentinel with Ursa
furiosa and that shield kept going I
literally just was like shields up
shields up and as long as I don't take
like one crappy like tank shot had died
I had it going for like three or four
times in a row that is to say he was
feeling sinister you was slow as soon as
it was bad
he's probably died of a car right he was
clover oh yeah he was yeah yeah so there
was you Sentinel and he got slow Luther
was there my brother I think he got
there I don't know what he was really
for the Cognito showed up to the party
late salute the stone for good hey no he
was like he was like he got a gun I was
like I don't have to do that again right
now I'm like I don't think so but yeah
there's there's more to it what did he
run if you could remember what to still
run I mean he always terribly will run a
Titan generally so it would be what
class like what generally will live on
Sentinel so he was probably some
variation to that also you was saying oh
and he was him yeah but I don't think he
was like you could have done more with
like throwing hammers or something with
range like that's it the Titans that no
shield had a benefit if you had other
people that could pump out that
like if I was sitting there with my
shield like holding defense and you like
there were two people with whispers
behind me like just pump and damage into
the boss or the tanks you could do some
work at the end but like you need two
other people doing damage if you're
gonna hold that shield like his super
really wasn't gonna be that useful like
throwing the shield man you wouldn't do
that much with it I said now you yeah do
it yeah getting out your flow you're
clearing the rule how long's about the
ink on like it's just people just won't
even last 20 min of mission I'll say no
like as far as how long you felt to get
on that encounter done like just that
part like how it's like six seven
minutes in comparison put it this way
the final fight of outbreak prime versus
the final fight of whisper I'm yeah like
how cuz whisper was room to room you
know I'm saying you had two things yet
to clear my head like you had four rooms
of enemies you have a lot more than that
in this one this one is harder for sure
huh
this whole thing you have two sets
enemies you have the tanks you have a
lot more shields you have the running in
the middle and then you have a fight in
the end which is just about as long so
that's the point where you have to be
fast on the front because you still need
about six minutes to be like okay so we
got him in the front okay soon as you
tag him he's gonna move okay soon as you
tag him he's gonna move you got to move
him around the room then work on the ads
and clear those and no it's it's harder
yeah you're you're stuck in a big box
gotcha and even around yeah I know I
don't want to be DPS straight up like no
he's not gonna stand still
yeah you can't sit in the back of the
room and snipe him no you got to be like
covering all sides so no it's harder for
sure in every way probably all right so
not at you you did it and the greatness
that amazing wrath of machine weapon one
of my favorite exotics tell me half the
image look sexy that's a freaking laser
vein man it's a laser beam and then the
sound effect the sound of head is so
specific to that guns like you hit the
precision you hit the precision kills
like like really well not like it's not
like a
Ching it's like I'm not doing it right
so I'm sorry everybody
different little sets like it's like
mechanical like we like it's the it's
all a little nanites basically so it's a
very specific sound every time you get
the precision kill that nanites pop out
and wait in their little cloud the
nanites are pretty powerful too they
will put some work in it's like senator
said nail gun it's laser beam crucible
it's solid oh I'll talk about that yeah
oh it's like I used it go yeah no no no
I'm gonna go facing facing y'all out
there Oh tough out here man
yeah right now yeah oh geez we gonna let
y'all rock for about two weeks then we
gonna start complaining don't mess with
my good old fight you can touch it in
PvP don't mess with this thing in PvE no
people you leave the how it is but Peavy
let me tell you right now I'm I told you
how I had this dominant build how I had
this nice run in comp and I was just
killing up everything yeah yeah got the
mob break prompts yo I can't even the t
TK is so fast if he has to drop run
don't even return fire run that's how I
learned I was gonna son by that gun then
it's luck at nanites and then I show
they add up they add up man and then
it's a great gun because so many people
clump up and conk
because they want a team shot a net that
thing is surrounded it's getting y'all
it's serious man it is very serious like
that is the meta and I struggle with
saying nerf it right now because
obviously look at all the work you guys
went to get it and I'm just you know be
careful him right in that regard but I
think TASKE said it already because I I
felt I was like oh this is I feel like
it's like old ago Chuck has to cross
this video he's not saying it's ope time
to kills not that fast check it out
though yeah yeah this is normal
outbreak perfected you haven't even got
the catalyst we're three were a couple
weeks from that so yeah mm-hmm girl when
that thing gets powered up even more and
get more nanites as what its gonna get
so I'm had to start snitchin today to
the to the competitive metal teams who
matters
yeah yes I gotta work on mine while I
can right get it now take advantage now
maze it's your world that he telling you
the mortal stings thought more people
meeting everybody in competitive it's
gonna have that thing soon as you get up
to the level so I mean it's all gonna be
there but yeah I'll be curious to see
how that one kind of pans out for PvP
but yeah there's also a catalyst this
serves a heroic version and that jumping
puzzle is completely different
what yep oh yeah I mean I'm a see see
man I thought it was just changing the
jumping puzzle stuff like a major chunk
of it is totally different and harder if
outside okay longer checkpoint okay
smaller little nooks Oh like small low
and no oh yeah platform now like
platforms upon touching like old Mario
games like witty drop in a shake aw come
on but it's really it's a mechanical so
it's just like being shook and they just
like go down I'm only gonna give them a
pass for one thing which I'm hoping
chain what returns in this arm in that
one would you floaties man you have the
easiest jump in the world to line up
don't don't I've done don't don't I've
done it
Paul Tassie if you're gonna go for
sources was even like being a hunter
like jumping puzzle on a hunters that's
your heart bowed listen all I'm gonna
say is what I do like that they did is
that they got this new mechanic that I
see which is if you hunters get ahead as
the Titans get ahead that you guys can
flip a switch and extend platforms for
the warlocks haha I like that that's
thinking of the bad jumper and that was
my issue Bungie that was my issue with
Charles Wood Whisperer like there's so
many people that get left behind he just
so frustrated cuz everybody's so far
ahead and they did a little so to help
the bad jumpers out so salute to them so
hopefully that carries over in a heroic
version you know our version of this
quest if there is one point of the
normal I think it's been normal because
I don't think you do in the hard one or
a warlock again here's the point of
advantage of warlock doesn't need an
exotic to make a gem
I have to have lion rampant on to make a
specific jump it's a shortcut you can
either go like down down down underneath
over over over up up or you can fall
jump and go oh yeah that's so bad at
jumping we have natural like mechanism
for mechanics will be fully glad you all
in midair stair break and then you move
yes you guys got all the verticality
right so we mr. jumping you don't rest
about us I did don't you got the triple
choice with Simone what's the one that
gives you you got the UH what's the old
deal with two one oh is that one what's
the name of those posts those kind of
bolts ah forget in my honor man I hardly
blame I'm talking about the hunters the
stomp a still have them
yeah it's Tom peas you know yeah yeah
he's like no I'm not on my hunter much
less a trip little bit yeah now it's the
mines the lion rampant cuz I have to do
the same thing wait to fall and then
catch it and and hopefully glide over
and hope my lion rampant hold it and
they knew I was like and you could
shorten that thing a big time because I
was watching sinner so like dude let me
catch up cuz he was on the warlock just
hitting the float I'm like I gotta see
if I can do this so I took a couple
attempts and finally made it so mm-hmm
no I mean Bert and this is again this
isn't gonna be something everybody loves
because you see like shackle shotgun she
put her collection of like Cosmo and
Dylan's post together and stuff like
that and they said we understand not
everybody enjoys punch jumping puzzles
this thing has it I was like and it just
does so it's like some people won't like
strikes like this new mission it's like
some people may be like hey this new
mission it's timed oh god that's so
stressful and there's jumping oh my god
like and so it's one of those points
where they do try and vary the content I
love it like me I love it obviously
because I'm biased I really try to yet
but from what I've seen I I'm cool too
you know why because again the
difference with the jumping that I see
here is that Wood Whisperer there was in
someone's antagonizing you that the mood
is as no human voice lying sick it's
annoying
yeah the music and music and whisper
though I still music and whisper still
maybe at this to me though because music
as I played if so much was so good door
slamming in there you know I'm saying
but wow I think I'm the
like this is that you don't remember
whisper you got bricks pushing you out
you got like all these hazards you got
like being taken dust poofing you into
the air it's so many things trying to
mess with you in route whereas this is
just jump it's just literally go here go
there shoot that do this go up like the
age like all of those things that mess
with you and they put him in Trevor
seriously I was like you get to that
point you're like oh I'm totally [ __ ] no
trust me all your other stuff that is
funny I could deal with that one I could
deal with trucker this seems Eliza oh I
got one entity chasing you so to speak
that's fun but all this push black move
this is going up this is rising the wall
is moving on nah fam I'm not trying to
do all that and then I'm jumping and
then this little low but though there
was it the taking poof thing and knocks
you into the air I'm good on it don't go
that so did this do some cool I like
what I see when you get done with the
hole when you get done with the heroic
version then we'll talk yeah but it has
a few tricks up its sleeve if somebody
doesn't know doesn't honestly most
people will run ahead and like so this
is something they did do in this one if
you are the first one through
you can basically hit switches to make
the jumps much easier that's what I was
help people get kicked no but I was
gonna say is like there's a certain
point in the heroic if you don't know
and like the first people trying to
figure it out there's a like fire things
over your head on a walking part where
it's just gonna basically cook you
really oh yeah it's not there in heroic
and it's the same room and you'd be like
oh I'm totally Paul never mind really
okay yeah so I mean people figure this
thing out they know where to go so this
one may feel easier and that may be why
in comparison to whisper but I guarantee
the whole mission overall harder for
sure
you just did the enemy fights twice but
like the jumping puzzle now that we know
how it works may be easier but in the
grand scheme like the there are certain
points having to figure out in the MoMA
late so there's a point called the vault
okay you lay in a room there's where do
you go
it's a closed-off room there's no
obvious doors there's one door with a
symbol on it where if you finally looked
around then the door opens when you go
up and like touch the wall so it's like
a secret door it's like an escape from
me like oh is this okay here we go now
we're out so like there's there's a lot
of stuff to it don't know it's like I'm
waiting there's a guy on Twitter and I
forget his name I'm thinking cactus
there's too many notifications out there
you like just poofed up when I know I
was like oh what and then yeah but no
nine hydra's senior world artists on
Bungie if you don't follow him follow
him because he said zero our art dump
incoming tomorrow whoa uh dope I'll go
check that one out for sure so so yeah
overall a tremendous an accomplishment
yeah I mean I loved it the heroics even
hurt you get your catalyst that way
there's this ridiculous puzzle that
people figured out so that thing's
actually been solved already so I'm not
even gonna try and solve that one and
that's within the the heroic
yeah it's within the heroic and I think
glad did the solo heroic full clear with
the void with this little key card crazy
he did all of what that and one run
apparently so Wow Wow whatever happens
with this whole puzzle is the more times
you hit it I guess more up to a certain
point you get time for doing it so it's
some sequence of that I don't know where
it all even works so yeah there's people
doing crazy stuff that I'm not gonna do
I was literally following esoterics
channel just to wait for him to put up a
solo it wasn't even 24 hours and it was
like salute to the non-human salute to
our angel friend man is a good thing
overall and you're having with the
weapon you'll run out is it maintained
its spot in your loadout right now can
you put your figure down for us so
here's the thing about it
that is surprising mmm so take a primary
verse almost any major or boss you're
just gonna like peck at them slowly this
thing starts building the mornin i'ts
you attack
the morning i'ts you attach just starts
working these guys like I watched my
damaged Manish go from like 2,000 3,000
4,000 5,000 per shot
oh I her bullet so it climbs so I tested
it on it's the fallen saboteurs like the
big servant uh south of trust land like
the one who bridge yes yes so I broke
his like little like drills 'edit roams
yet and then I just put up my rally
barricade and just started firing and I
want to just record that to see the
numbers climb because it was like I
swear doubled the damage of purple it
but that's the Paris nanites like the as
you as you split mountain and they start
attaching to it you know more and more
damage that are their GPS is let you
talk and underlord level stuff like
because that's what Thunder all you do
kinda but this sounds even more intense
because as more nanites are getting on
it's really intensifying damage and
draining the boss well you have people
like sweat cycle that went out there and
basically like one phase Calais Calais
with it insertion wait how many had
outbreak perfective probably all of them
play to them without yeah it's stupid
fast then thing is you can see your
little nanites with the little red glow
around yours anybody else who has
orbital or outbreak crime I was called
the wrong name anybody who has outbreak
perfected their little white ones so you
can see your friends stopped everybody
got they coordinated then yeah well
everybody else has a white I actually
don't know what the little things look
like in PvP I don't know if I've seen
him enough Wow yeah in white yeah we did
go phantom Forge
yeah just sitting there put any major
heavy that you can put some work into
now especially if you get rally
barricade to get it going fast if you'd
like well of Radiance with loose luta
factions like well well with luna
faction all you're just gonna start
messing some stuff up and it's a primary
remember animals not an issue so as
damage starts ticking on there it's
gonna be putting in some work so though
you get a new room with those things
you're gonna be you need to work it i
don't know if people have done it
against ribbon data has of
was gonna watch like insertion crime I
know people like I don't know if that
one phased instruction prime or not but
yeah it was so this this is the case
that if they did that a month because
that was a net raid race when it comes
to what we're gonna talk about next this
one may be involved I'll just say that
so before my prediction though I think
they gonna let us eat right now is he
any of your for other gonna nerf it come
June for this did it's gonna cuz they
got to introduce new stuff and remember
done the lawyer I just run but then they
hit it nobody hit machine guns no it did
take a loan they gonna let us rock I
would say they give us a strong I give
us a power strong month what we got with
me Jul we're probably will probably like
I would say not the immediate at all
season opulence no matter of fact they
may they may we might throw that in that
debt I guess like a little stealth patch
towards it to eight uh September but was
I mean it you excuse me real see I was
like again this is one of those you put
the gun out there you make it hard to
get you better not take it away that
fast
so shout out a shout out to havoc by the
way big time supporter and four months
of subs so thank you guys much brother
the right place man in the right place
so yeah I mean it's been it's been crazy
since Tuesday it just like started
ground runnin working on it that night
got the gun then worked on heroic the
next night shout out to is a NIM and
pyro who took me through heroic because
I got a point where like going through
her row cuz like my second time so I'm
still learning the jump puzzle they
basically finished the boss room without
me because they got there so fast
but one thing to note actually oh you
know you are behind all right if you are
behind far enough I had to redo the
entire Trevor room it didn't hold so I
had to redo the whole thing by myself
with him in there so they were far
enough ahead and I was like I would
tried to go run to the end and the door
was not open I was like what see so
Iranian got to the end was like guys I
gotta redo this whole thing
see that's that's that's that right
there that's the type of stuff I keep
reeling you in and then smacking you in
the face see you I was all good until
you said that
oh man that is so me I could see you is
sinister like so far hang and I'm like
yeah here's the room is this thing
chasing me is it wise I gotta press the
buttons good and I didn't honestly know
I was like far enough behind that
apparently I'd like admit it was the
heroic puzzle stuff like that when I was
going through and I told them I was like
alright so I got to the end with like
maybe two minutes left they were doing
most of the work on the boss and I came
in and you know I at least had
whispering oh so I had some benefit but
yeah that was rough anyway we're not
gonna talk over but this set although
all otherwise in that this giant sounds
fired man it's great thing for the
community look the gun looks beautiful
the orc but not the second ornament but
the first one you can buy yeah I might
actually have to buy this one
haven't seen none of the ornaments yet
alright though but throw money at the
screen it's throw money the screen what
one of them but I think is a must for me
the other one doesn't do as much for me
it's a cool color scheme don't get me
wrong but the other one is so much
better I probably would never use the
second one but that default looks so
sexy I'm looking at that fortress well
it's a normal one looks good I mean you
don't really need it but the other one
hold on let me see if I can get out
break somebody's gonna have them up
there mm-hmm
it just it Hawkins me to rather the
machine and but I love that is it may
not be everyone's best rate but that
rate is the most fun to me I have so
much fun the dodgeballs I even go to
music really just go to Google go to
Google real quick outbreak perfected
ornament then just go to images it's
literally the first to just go perfected
a juicer I would do that because the one
yeah it's like the rusted there
rested the green gold lake kinda looks
like you know you put a slit like a
shader on a sleeper gun but no the first
one it's like see corruption spreading
it's some of my dad that golden black
kind of thing not the golden green not
the golden dark green no it's the other
one with like the orange stripe like the
infection looking sickness rust on it
like that one looks really sick
literally it's the first two on my
screen whatever okay do you find it it
keeps showing me that same one whatever
alright anyway but yeah there's there's
one that I finally might have to have to
buy so you talk about that bust it look
at 101 it look like it's infected yeah
yeah do you keep that that one look like
it got yeah I got a guy like that one
you like that one yeah I actually do
like it like no it's like it's either
normal outbreak perfected with the red
and the black for sure I can't go to the
other one with like the green and the
yellow on and like it looks like it
looks like its own like you know color
scheme cool but it looks like a shader
got slapped on there the other one looks
unique like I like that unique I'll give
you and I think wouldn't that with that
ornament on there somebody who's saying
there's an animation to it as well like
when you fire
oh really there's like an effect or
something so I don't know if it's just
all it always does that or something or
what but yeah it's definitely the things
so now you can keep the AIDS patient
whoa whoa whoa I like I like that Oh
actually I'm staying with the fault I'm
staying with the fault I mean yeah the
faults damn good so it's really already
know so yeah I was good for uh oh yeah
so those popped up as soon as you get
the gun those are at you know ever verse
so the ornaments severe uh but yeah all
in all I mean it's been fun heroics its
own thing I haven't even done the key
card extra puzzle which is gonna get you
so you get twenty print so that it is
interesting because it's one thing
the center Street kind of pointed it out
and I don't know as somebody or no maybe
it was pyro the catalyst the way you get
the catalyst is you can't apply the
catalyst therefore you can't make orbs
until you finish it mo can't start it
and then work on the progress to get the
perk activated the way basically
everything works right now the way it's
but it still sits out there unactivated
until you completely finish the bar so
it's a different way for it to work so I
don't that's what they were saying is
like I honestly wonder cuz more spoilers
by the way in case you're wondering in
three two one
data mining for most of the catalysts
for your twos done all right which guy
well we got well we got could we spoil
uh yeah let me get the list I suppose
can spoil the populists oh well we're
not you know catalyst is about date and
that's my thing I need to know okay so
we don't know what the perks are okay
come on forum stop open and crazy
advertisements so data miners have
uncovered a treasure trove so shout out
to Paul test as when he was I'm pretty
sure there's always this is just a list
quick when I found em so there have been
so here's a list of your to catalyst
that have been found and a glimpse of
what they'll do now sometimes you know
that perks that actually change it up in
case there's you know other things to it
this is your stats basically is what the
glimpses are and again this is where
data miners sometimes can like try to
ruin some stuff shoutout but there's
only so much they can do when you PC
people just figure it out and break it
down right most of it actually ends up
coming from the API though so
malfeasance cool mouth easy range but we
got plus twenty mmm Cerberus plus one
stability and a reload plus twenty okay
I guess so right you know it's funny I
lose it do you even I don't use it
either
whatever Black Talon magazine plus 40mm
wave splitter still gonna wait on that
one exclusive range plus ten ammo
capacity plus thirty sounds good
thousand voices
getting a catalyst stability plus 30
ammo capacity plus 20 which is probably
like one more round one more round
yeah Trinity ghoul charge time plus 20
Lord of wolves magazine plus 40 stop
don't you start
are you serious that's the only weakness
in that gun Oh sir we did so many thing
at a chat a personal champion cement
touch this corner right now it's in
video oh it's in this ballgame late a do
it go face you're ready
Oh Queen breaker and this is one where
everybody's like are you kidding range
+20 aim-assist plus 20 somebody was like
the first place I saw us it was this
list it was like Queen blanker range
plus 20 Amos is plus 20 parentheses
mellow elk I would tell you right now if
I don't hear sleeper simulant on this
list do for this and this little orangey
queen break is getting all this love and
this cold man don't get me started don't
get me started with my hate and finally
issues two-tailed Fox range plot
reload speed plus 30 weapon size plus 10
so probably one more than faster reloads
oh let me tell you right now I just got
that that yo-yo two tailed is very
effective very effective and especially
since the have you used it since the all
rocket launchers across the board I've
gotten the buff uh-huh bro take out two
up two tail right now late to attend
time solo and stuff crazy with that it
is very effect the only weakness is that
reload animation it does take a while
dad is serious missile for me it's gonna
be that to tail that Lord that annoying
Queens breaker cuz I gotta see what do
and then um no stuff I don't really use
the other stuff to be honest you said
could you say like Cerberus was on in
you said Trinity goal it's really I
don't really yeah there's just there's
but I mean there's that list has been
late God knows when they're coming
supposedly I will say for other
for those of you guys who don't have the
faction rally catalysts
those are suppose that coming in the
summer I have heard that yeah because
I'd be we'd be graviton grab some chard
and sweet business sweet business yeah
grab at some people because ever since I
went to pcs no way for me to get dope
Joe alright this is cool this is cool I
like this I don't know when those are
coming that's there in the idea there
somewhere yeah they got it they just got
to get my sleeper back man I got to do
something for me that's all I'm only
complaint other than everything cool so
yeah that's most of kind of what dropped
with the patch patents were somewhat on
the minimal side I do have to say I
don't think they were anything totally
in Asia I mean we had spectral blades
can I get their adjustment I haven't
seen an abundance of those in PvP I have
it's still doing them though they're
there they're still getting read but it
I wouldn't say is it obnoxious I felt
you know when I lost to it it was it was
fair you know I'm saying it's but it's
still dominant its I didn't feel like oh
you know it's so you know whatever but
you know it is what it is so I mean
nothing else too crazy in the patch
women basically it was just this thing
got like tucked in with the patch so
they could finally activate it and then
people of course basically what happened
was I think I don't know if people would
have known to look if the adventure
didn't move and then somebody wants to
go looking the API thinking about the
exotic quest somebody checked like GG
and the masterwork catalyst was out
there because that's the first thing I
saw on Twitter was the little graphic of
the masterwork catalyst image and
showing like the outbreak perfected like
a little yeah the war mine type effect
on the weapon so how crazy is it as a
desti fed by just the outline of a gun
oh yeah I know what it I scrapped
community you know what it is that's
iconic stuff right yeah annex so this
point over under on I just play over
under on Gallo on let's do it now
oh if it's coming back I don't want it
to I still don't
but do you think it is no mmm think they
keep it out that's a trump card they can
hold
do I know I don't want them to they
brought it back model why do you one
no if I don't know I hope not
honestly I say no because it'll take the
wind out of the other sails down granted
to be the only rocket launcher worth a
damn probably but again that would be
your like required again cuz if rocket
launcher is as powerful as they are it
would hit like a truck as you're saying
so what I mean they they did it in your
one and then took it away and then they
brought it back in Destiny one they
don't need to bring it back to breath
like for the third time I think it's
good
I completely I'm with you I guess my
question is will they actually keep
because at this rate looks like gonna be
like is that gonna be May or June or
July of 2020 before you know like next
gen or something like that to like have
somebody if we look at if we look at it
objectively we're getting literally
every iconic gum back so far yeah we're
getting a lot of it and and the rumors
already got hot bone in the database you
know and saying we wait and I heard
rolls which is new but you know that's
their playing off of that but at least a
good thing about this this was not
another hand can to something very yeah
I was a pulse rifles nice to have what
you know my wheel s sitting in there I
didn't want to ask you though like
literally on that point would you have
rather had a new gun I mean they're not
really perfected then outbreak then out
yeah then outbreak crime perfect or
whatever oh okay yeah I was gonna say it
has a lot of nostalgia it is a fun gun
the quest was crazy hard before this one
is it easy it's cool but would you'd
rather had something new or just like
hey here you know we brought this one
forward to in this case because the
package they dressed it in with such
fans for such Thal juh and again so many
people are fans of that race so many
people are fans have gone back to the
tower so many people love you know Siva
and that whole thing and then lore
behind that's a very I wouldn't say it
was like it showed me how much people
loved it cuz to be honest I thought it
was just a gun that I really know what
am i baby no say important if it just
goes to show you man like I think I
think this was the right call because in
a defense let's be real um black armory
really gave us a lot of new
I mean we got Joe tool you know I'm
saying Izanami what was it I didn't even
get that yet there's an Arn
yup bird and I haven't gotten that you
know we got a lot of cool new stuff and
it you know blast furnace is running out
there the machine guns came bags
everywhere yeah my head it's a beast you
know I'm saying like black arm we got
some serious serious weapons so I think
they did well there um as far as exotics
as long as the reason why I'm so good
with this it's not another damn Anke
yeah I'm with you there like yeah so
give us some variety I'm kind of tired
of the hand cannons at this point yeah
yeah yes I'm with it I'm with I mean and
I'm confident they got more new stuff
redacted that's cooking it so yeah
that'll be interesting and that'll kind
of roll into what we got coming next is
the table so yes sir
twelve basically they do a little talk
about zero hour which is the mission
they show a little bit on Trevor for the
terrifying nature but yeah it's
basically everything about outbreak
perfected so yeah we got a whole new
topic of conversation now so this is
gonna be what is its crown sorrow is
that a little dream our current which
here go for it go for it alright and
shout out to uh havoc you can in check
let me go and drink my water hold on get
that water man that's right
having said we got do it stay hydrated
everybody drinks yeah hey there buddy
listen to this if you got any water near
you grab a sip of water never drink
enough of that stuff for sure just right
now if you want you a little you know
propel what is your bad know what - so
season of opulence
whoa we have our first little tidbit of
information yes sir
so I'm gonna read through most of this
actually because it's not the longest
thing in the world and then we'll talk
about it I just want everybody out there
to kind of have a feel completely feel
like they know what Bungie is trying to
say and then we'll go from there so
starting June 4th season of opulence
kicks off for all players of Destiny -
so as we all figured that was the date
had no shocks there many of you are
familiar with how raids can launch with
new content usually on a Friday a reset
this season we're doing something a
little different owners of the annual
pass will be
to conquer a new raid on day one hold
your thumb hold that thought here's some
context on this new plan and changes to
the upcoming power climb dev team the
world's first race for a raid as a
competitive event the raid is a
challenge geared towards testing a fire
teams ability to learn and execute the
mechanics so well is their ability to
overcome enemies and bosses together
having a short window of time between
release and launch allows us to preserve
the combat challenge for players making
their attempt on day one and get people
playing a raid content right away
crown of sorrow June 4th 4:00 p.m.
Pacific time recommended power for first
encounter 715 case you guys are
wondering that time frame reset is
typically 10 a.m. Pacific so it's a six
hour difference with this race there
will be a few minor changes to current
investment systems to ensure an even
playing field while players are
increasing their power at launch of the
season last mission scores will be
unavailable until crown of launch has
been beaten this prevents from players
with stash of ethereal keys from having
a leg up on the race prime attunements
will be reset to two charges per
character on day 1 while characters
build prime attunement charges over time
these are being set to 2 per character
upon logging in after the new season
begins all level 50 players can earn
prime engrams after signing in and
playing during season of opulence
players may continue to build prime
attunement over time after the reset
occurs as a reminder any powerful
bounties acquired prior to season of
opulence will have the power cap at 700
if you're the type of the type to take a
day off of work to celebrate the start
of a new season get their quest sitting
down or officially four weeks away from
season of opulence we'll have more
information on what's changing in
destiny 2 but for now just keep your
ears open mm-hmm so we're gonna start at
the top for one June 4th so yes of
course no surprise
um yeah yeah it's just kind of hit this
thing straight in the face crowd of
sorrow first the title like it like it I
like it BAM I'm intrigued because um I
want to grow fat from strength
you want to go face Calais for real I
will get the ball you know say he's the
we know we cleaned this attic we dusted
off the roof put new tiles up there we
got a catalog out of it you don't and we
did American Ninja for him you know like
so we killed his robot Butler so now
it's time to meet the man and what is it
that he is offering us so I'm very
curious about this I think they can seal
this thing off put a nice chair I'm
actually pretty confident in this one
for some reason I hope I'm not wrong but
I'm confident so I like the name so
that's that's number one
cool mm-hmm okay so that's the name too
and this is the bigger one of all time
so most resets will happen on June 4th
at will happen on a Tuesday at 10:00
a.m. Pacific they've been good about
getting stuff like even patches they'll
be down for like literally 15 minutes
before and little honest they'd be right
back up at their typical reset time
mm-hmm now one thing with regards to the
time that some people have been talking
about is pre loading this content if
you're gonna have the race on a six hour
window from when you log in until that
thing goes live every minute counts
facts people on ps4 have to download
them and copy consoles internet
connections all those things it's a
factor so in depending on if you want PC
things just work a little quicker so
some people are definitely asking us all
cactus do it I saw a couple others yeah
yeah just pre download a content now
here's the other side of that what's up
when you pre download you have all the
people in PC rip apart that API again so
secrets treasures questions like that
get opened up mm-hmm so I can see both
sides of that argument pretty much
straight away is the secrecy they're
gonna be looking at it like they'll know
every raid weapon before we step in
there like stuff like that's gonna be a
worry and that's one thing I don't know
how much they can hold because they can
open up an activity yeah but they can't
like if you download the day base of
stuff on your like
then you have it or the api's except
like those are gonna be there but in
turn in fairness mm-hmm I think you have
to let people get to this thing you
think you have to preload it to
something good like I don't know how far
or how much I mean some people with
internet connections you need to preload
like night at least day before like you
need to give people 24 hours to download
oh yeah you give me 24 hours ahead of
time to me it's a non-issue like 24
hours
download your joint you want to be ready
day 1 you know what to do I mean we this
is not we've been through this song and
dance before the community actually said
but it's like you know the community
they know what to do man you got to get
ready
um are we gonna get into the date you
know like I'm about to go but I know
you're breaking it down and let me know
what what next fault we might talk about
I'm just literally going down the text
line by line here no yeah I have no
problem with that
recommended power for the first
encounter 715 interesting lasting and
they specifically say first encounter
right Dasom yeah so one what do you
think of that power level for six hours
- well what do you think it's gonna end
up at and then are you gonna be there
first day I mean listen are you working
on that day that here's the thing I'm at
e3 that look I'm live it's June 4th when
do you go out there like it I'm bugging
you're right I'm driving told you like a
bunch it starts like Friday so smart
timing Bethenny so like III like
Saturday Sunday Friday whenever you
start if they wait until Friday that's
when people would really be like going
out getting ready stuff starting
Saturday like right now you've got it on
Tuesday so you're not messing with that
yeah I mean listen it's gonna be a
crunch there's no doubt see I'm not
gonna get fooled by this because on
paper this sounds reasonable right but
then we all remember when lash was
dropped and we got to Cali
we were like recommended is it did you
felt the wrath of that power level so
you know it's gonna be one of those
things that you know a well-coordinated
team
who knows the mechanics who have good
strats who are able to figure it out
will be underleveled and/or at level and
be able to do it but I bet you're still
gonna be pretty tough
and based on the verbage again if we
look at the dev teams verbage before you
know they want it to be this whole you
know competitive event but at the same
time as far as the launching at the
content you know what that power climbs
so I think this is still gonna be tough
man I still think it's gonna be tough
but I mean as we continue on did this so
far everything for me is the right
approach but let's continue all right
well I mean for me on the recommended
power yeah sorry
no but I mean if you think if it's at
that slow pace if you're like from 700
to 750 is not that quick pace it's
Prime's its weekly really like daily
stuff like 15 power levels in like 6
hours that's the first encounter man you
were might link that's mmm that's tough
I was like that's a you're not I don't
know I mean if you're 715 you had I mean
and they're still orangey in this too
which is gonna be a thing right there's
still gonna be that there but I mean you
think about what about right yeah but
you limited primes but you also think
about Kali being what did she was like
560 and then um like ribbon into being
like 585 90 so I mean that's another
like that's like 2030 power levels yeah
in that 6 hours so here's the question
and like before we get to anything else
what I was like so do you think it's the
people who do 6 hours of work and then
just go in and like try and bash their
heads against it or you think people are
like hey we're gonna set a timer and go
12 hours we're gonna work on the
leveling we're gonna work on this where
we are and then at 12 hours then we're
gonna start jumping in bro I am all
about this smoke let me tell you why
because you know I've been on record for
saying it's been unfair from longtime
there's normal people who want red
jackets right and there's people that I
know that are normal people that when
new destiny contact comes out they take
off work
they plays they wanna be world's first
you know I'm saying I got guys like like
gaming at it I know that and I'm saying
sinister these guys take off work they
have ready to go and the unfair
advantage was as soon as I started oh
let's save all our primes from you know
and all our bounties from I am better
and all nah fam
now we gonna see this one is the real
one what was getting this jacket no
directed all the jack holders but
whoever's getting this jacket I
personally have a lot of respectful
because this is gonna be great they're
not playing you going it's gonna be
right at launch everybody's in the mix
not as much cheating strategy's not a
much was that key holding that we gonna
get into don't care no girls no bears no
no this is what I'm talking about I want
to see Joe Schmoe from Wichita that
wanted some dude in Oregon I want to see
some guy that we never heard of and we
like yo that's what I'm talking about
I don't want to see no disrespect I just
want to see a common person who puts
that commitment in takes the day off
says you know what we got to get this
light up we're gonna blaze out from the
fourth on and and and this it's fair man
it's fair that's why I'm really loving
so far everything that I'm hearing it
show came out can can they shout at the
bag of mondo I was just wanna hear man I
want to see those stories with listen
it's all good when our favorite
streamers are up there and they're
winning but come on he how cool would it
be right
somebody that or just yourself you know
I'm saying like you just you were stone
and I'll be like yo no my boys okay if
that actually happened I'd like laugh so
hard exactly but but you but I would
know you took off work you put into work
and you guys figured it out and
everybody's battling how think about the
screens now on that world's first
because now I didn't know disrespect not
calling nobody out but your favorite
streamer right we gotta pay attention to
two or three favorite streamers we're
gonna be looking at everybody Joe cannot
forget it oh wow you know saying like
he's here
and they think about this think about
the growth for a little Channel right oh
yeah God like there's gonna be some
people that get some love on this one I
want to see those small content creators
shine bro I really do and if one of the
big guys do it great but at least I know
that everybody was in the mix this time
yeah you know that's all right over but
I'm loving this II I know it's tough I'm
not gonna say it's not it's tough what
they're asking like you say 15 power
level you know that's gonna be tough to
do that in that short amount of time
4:00 p.m. Pacific Standard Time goes
live you know you're gonna it's gonna be
a tough crop there's no doubt about it
but I want to see this is a new approach
and I'm very shocked that they took I
want to see how it plays out so this
will be the and this is gonna go back to
a question that you didn't even answer
yet
sorry no no you're good I'll let you go
because honestly you're saying a lot of
things I was thinking about like no it's
fair I like how it's like I mean it is
rng is probably the only thing that's
gonna be like the question mark for a
lot of people be like I got like six
marks in a row man I'm out like I mean
you're almost gonna have to have like
people on your bench just being like
dude I got the best orgy in the world
I'm ready to go like those are probably
gonna be a thing for sure
but like what I wanted to say is what do
you think the strategy is gonna be do
you feel it is take your six hours burn
what you can get in there and do you
think you'll be able to beat it or do
you think it's like take 12 hours me
like hey we're working longer like what
does that matter what do you think like
what do you think is gonna be that like
point of and then some people are saying
this too is like what do you have like
six people go in you got six people in
bench still levelling watching the
stream learning the encounters mm-hmm
bale got one of them in he's a little
more powerful and start switching people
do you think they're gonna let me do you
think they're gonna do do you think that
takes away from the world's first if
there's like you know twelve people
involved in this thing or something like
that I'd actually don't because I think
it becomes more communal I think it
becomes you know people looking at
straddle more people you know what I'm
saying and I'll see you power level is
going to be key but if you got someone
who effectively runs strats i mean shout
out I believe that's the Megerian those
guys when everybody was going through
the last wish controversy of how hard it
was initially you know shout the frame
oh my god
yes but you had him by the way hosting
DCP now ACP yes a friend
absolutely the hopefully see them at a
guardian car and Ares and chat by the
way areas of course run on the Big Show
over there doing good things out there
in the DCP shout out to area sir
salute the Ares man DCP good good people
man and um yeah it's like I said the end
of the day is just like you know I
understood the argument but destiny Gary
did prove that if the strats work with
you know what to do effectively yes I
mean look dps is gonna be dpi you know
that right but if you know what to do
effectively and you have to figure that
out that kind of helps you know so you
know you're gonna be tagging in people
with power level you might not you know
I'm saying but I don't really worry
about this one I know I know what you're
going with it but I don't really worry
with that aspect honestly like it's just
gonna be everyone's in the same plane
feel that's how I look at it about you
are you concerned no I'm not concerned I
would say I'm just honestly wondering
what's gonna be the way to go I'm
wondering is that like do you think if
like say glad and sweats ago and his
crew like they go be like alright so you
know raid secrets crew goes in there
they get as much as they can they get to
like say they get like seven tents at
eleven 709 whatever they get then they
go to the raid like six hours in they
start bashing their head against the
wall okay we get through the first
encounter over six levels below see the
next one in psych hall man it's like
7:25 crap the next one is like 735
they're getting underleveled but is are
they gonna be the ones who can like
power through and just execute or is it
gonna be somebody who and like if
they're bashing your head against the
wall the fights really tough they're
people other people are watching people
learn the encounters as a mistake in
extra time that's literally what I was
like take extra time and just keep
leveling keep love out keep leveling and
then go be like all right so we gonna go
like go nuts at like 12 hours or
something take this time get a couple
hour an hour plague take your 6 hours of
run get like eight hours sleep for a few
see what the strats are wake up and then
go you you run risks all the way risk
either way you won't risk because you
can go another level and be like crap
now we showed people what to do they've
been leveling for awhile take you stay
and then they'll take
right and go and move on to the next
encounter or on the other side is like
hey you may be the first one to it and
be able to do it but it's like honestly
my worry if they bumped that level they
say they go 715 725 735 and you walk in
there like 710 25 power level difference
what's huge that's nice to hit maybe a
situation you know we don't get that
till Saturday you know I would love if
it was not beaten in 24 hours
yeah I don't think so I don't think so
I would love if that happens now is like
there are people who will lose sleep
over it there are people who are 24
hours and 2 minutes hats off to that
gentleman yeah
today doe but man like I think it would
be really cool if actually it was like
the key was to wait to level and then go
a bit later so it wasn't that first day
like it's done and it's done and release
day it would be the first time it didn't
happen cuz that's never not let me let's
go back in time um
forth of glass was that if that wasn't
available day one this is this is unique
no orator oh yeah they've never done day
one ever right shout out tomorrow I just
put up Lords Gaming that NIT check that
out cha put it in there but um yeah I
just talked about it and I said this is
a monumental shift in approach and this
is them prepping differently and this is
an experiment I like to see shout out
the carpet man for bringing me down to
earth here's the relay if that's a rain
oh it's a raid they said it officially
it's all right you're right you're right
everything in this thing has been six
player raid now question what did they
call scourge of the past they called
raid but again they said knock crota not
like last which level but also not in
Rota they put it in between so again
it's mm raids have different levels like
Lauer's Jamis okay Ares say crotas end
was day one was it totally forgot that
then damn yeah cuz I glad you said that
areas because I was there I was shadowed
smell go flameless plugboard
look um the thing was I was like and I
stayed away from using that verb
because I wasn't sure and maybe a cool
it was I didn't think about it
immediately available upon the
expansion's really except wow yeah he's
right okay so this is their going back
to that you know thing at the end of the
day this is I like it man
I like I'm excited like this is the type
of stuff I love about destiny and this
is where shout out the attic employees
not here hopefully listens
it's just what a raid does this is this
see how we talking right now what it
feel good this is this is beautiful I
love to see this aspect of strats and
everybody getting ready and people
complain it and you look at it other
people screen and you're like damn in
here how do they do this it's Oscar
grayskin glorious man the fort is good
Laureus can't wait so you log in you
check out your new six player match made
activity what is that
isn't that gonna be worth like the
highest boosting gear is the new
activity in six hours gonna get tried to
figure out so you can get enough of a
boost to go jump into the new race the
same day actually I was gonna say
depending on what else comes with this
season of opulence they are front
loading the-- six player match mate is
gonna get burned through and figure it
out fast cuz you know that's gonna be
worth it for drops the rate is getting
it figured out in a couple of days this
is gonna be a front-loaded season i have
a bet listen no i'm no i was like do you
think that's right do you think it's
gonna be fairly front-loaded okay so i
mean i mean i I don't know I don't want
to comment because remember we got six
player other activity redacted we had
like two other maybe one other two other
redacted other redacted yeah we don't
know you know um I don't I think we go
see uh-uh-uh-uh-uh all I'm going to say
is I don't know what to expect but I am
excited for opulence I've always been
consistent on opulent always said
opulence I feel they're gonna be in
pocket and this ends off the deal you
know the Activision deal you know I'm
saying the question becomes after what
do they do you know I'm saying I know
we'd get into that a little bit but um
because we know September and I just saw
what's coming and I told
and oh boy so um yeah that the question
then becomes what are they doing you
know get into that but this is I'm
liking this man I'm liking this a lot
it's a nice experiment for them to test
out to see how this approach works and
what does the college community adjust
is the what strats like you said right
does everybody apply yeah I think that
would be the biggest thing to watch is
like what the strategies already people
do this do they just work on leveling do
they take like I mean what if you just
say hey let's take two more hours and
get a few more pal what if it's just
like two hours that makes it mm oh
they'll be like he'd interview later
later on Bungie done I'd be like all
right so you guys were the raid team
what was your strategy on day one so
what did you do and they put the mic in
front of their face like on the TV
screen what we did we talked before we
worked for about six hours what we're
like hey we know it's gonna be tough we
saw the level of the encounter somebody
did jump head here's another 10 levels
so we went ahead and committed we stuck
with it we level for like three more
hours then we jumped in we jumped on
their piggy back so we jumped off of
them win and finish it up like I'll be
like I can see some hilarious stuff in
there so that'll be really really cool
I'm looking forward to watching for one
I mean I might be off I don't mean I'll
I'll give a shot let's go let's get that
raised put your feet in me let's go I
was like ever what oh it was Navi labs I
was with he goes NIM and black link I
was with those for a little bit on Iowa
labs and we were trying to like figure
out the puzzles and levels and stuff and
it is the feeling of kind of being in
that rush even if you're behind just
being like hey we're trying to go
through okay we're on this alright they
figured this was okay we hit that one
okay or like it's that moment with Jenny
there it's right let me tell you bro it
is nothing I've I'm very old game my
iron Lord for I will tell you right now
in gaming when a destiny ray is done
right when you got those taken King last
wish you know I'm saying all the great
ones you know I'm saying like when you
have a good raid and everyone's watching
is this world first going there it is
the best cooperative experience in
gaming I'll stand on it I'm telling you
it is so much going to do a raid blind
man rat the machines the only one I did
never forget him it was so much fun
right you really enjoy and instead of me
of the chunk of that blind actually
remember it's it's so fun yeah I know
you'd never get in I love the way again
went first right we just came on offer
second as the last great one so fun to
see I stood up
watching was it was it redeemed I've got
was it I watched on boys get it in man
and out like you seemed like the tears
enjoy it we're like 18 hours right row
it's just amazing that's what Bungie
does best that's what I'm so confident
in this company because I know what
they're capable when they've already met
this mountaintop so many times it's like
this look what they put an outbreak
prime boom got the feels right back no
no these boys they could do it man they
can do it so I'm ready yeah kind of hard
to top that one for stuff to talk about
blur it yeah so that's gonna be a very
interesting time could put your requests
days off into work if you need them plan
ahead cuz yeah first couple of days
gonna be interesting yeah ether comes
directly after that mmm so we were kind
of talking about this offline now you
were saying it's like hey you were
thinking they might hype stuff up for
like III and things like that this is
all gonna be basically most everything's
gonna be out there before III even goes
they might have a calendar of a couple
things come in a week or two later where
there's the six player like maybe on the
next week something like that during e3
when do you when do you think they talk
about what's whatever is next when do
you think that discussion happens what
do you even try it or anything um nah I
think you got a stack that new cycle
strategically they've placed it before
e3 for a reason
you know I mean like we talked offline
you know Sony's not gonna be there
during this period Sony has the
marketing bytes so they're not gonna be
the activision does not do their own
conference so they're not gonna be there
and um
you know so this is anymore they don't
matter
you said it but uh at the end of the day
it's like okay let's mark it the hell
out of it despite their mentality
they do it that week before you know um
now as far as your question as far at
the next right yeah this will be
opulence yeah right up before or late
May last content info okay it drops like
June fourth rain go to e3
okay what's now right right I think they
still gonna ride the way if we're still
gonna get um like end of May I mean end
of a counter right now so like and the
June they're still gonna be probably
trip
no I'm saying arm as far as talking
about the very next kind of gotta do it
almost in a you know to muff cadence
right so it's so I yeah I say chill is
because you know what wait wait lens
Guardian con that's the one so I third
Virgil I fifth sixth seventh fifth and
say you go I'll be a couple days extra
what what good promo communities they
already everyone we know we gonna be out
yeah you saw in beach to st. hey I just
got done talking about Guardian con
people about planning to be there and I
was like before they brought Canberra
and we knew what it was mmm-hmm so it's
like do they do a review do they what do
you think really reveal at Guardian
Colleen their prey not a problem
they're probably not gonna be that would
be a hell of a win for yeah they'll
probably released new content for
opulence cuz it's still gonna be in in
stride cuz June 4th is when it rocks
right so then we got a month so we right
then after the monthly furries dying
down they're gonna drop I think they're
gonna drop something opulence II during
that time period technical term yeah so
um yeah like I feel they're gonna do do
something near like maybe you know some
type of stealth exotic tribe you know or
whatever whatever some quest something
like that do that I still don't think we
hear anything about the next phase
oddly August I'm going with August no no
that's what you're going with
I mean yeah late July August I was
thinking I was like it really late July
I would say I don't think
to rush and honestly at that point
hopefully our wonderful debate and
questions will be answered to be like
we'll see what the plan is and then
we'll see how it's received we'll see if
anything in the futures effect if
they'll be like I'll be really funny to
be like oh I got my I got my combat
expansion they come up be like hey we
want to work on d3 that's gonna end this
is like 2028 we want to take three look
I got yours and then be like I got mine
to be like well apparently we both won
I've officially changed course
seen what's going on yeah I was like in
September we now have the date of
September 6 Monster Hunter ice-born it's
a monster underworld ice for and it's a
big one
yeah you got Borderlands 3 the next week
so I mean that's both weeks right there
and I'm not saying Monster Hunter is
gonna take away as much what he eats but
I was like it's it's a damn fun game
like i play that on playstation and like
when ice boards coming I wonder if I'll
actually play through back on PC again
at that point because it would be kind
of a good time
mm-hmm have a good one havoc I will
catch you having a little brother thank
you bro yeah listen man I mean and and
what you were talking about
yeah Borderlands is gonna be a force so
big mm-hmm yeah I was just announced
yesterday so not even the biggest I mean
back in the day I used to be a ghost
recon guy right but I'm gonna tell you
right now PD I know me you were going
shots not though in the chat me and him
we're going back and talking offline
about the reveal he's division to the
death but I'm gonna tell you right now
I'm gonna give you our sneak preview one
of my topics ILP this Sunday I saw that
trailer you didn't see the 15 minute one
I am telling you right now Ghost Recon
looks phenomenal
like I had no expected well Angela it's
okay it was cool I mean as sinister
played a couple of people played it you
know Arizona like have fun and co-op but
that's like it yeah and it's it that's
his base but the dig would do all the
new things that they do it like they're
talking about it's very stealth oriented
they're talking survival stuff you know
it looks
graphic engine whatever they're using
snow drop with the third person now man
it looks for now you can jump in
vehicles and
it's doing things divisions not doing
dens what surprised me which I told you
was great I was like Ghost Recon as a
raid what what is going on so yeah man
like listen I Wow wildlands definitely
was ok to me it wasn't terrible but it
was ok but breakpoint Ghost Recon
breakpoint looks phenomenal I encourage
you guys watch the gameplay trail which
is about I mean the UM the trailer
reveal first which is about maybe five
minutes son like that then watch the
official gameplay which is like 15
minute of the story looks good it looks
like they got a consistent store where
they got my man Jon Bernthal can't
pronounce the last name
Punisher my boy punished from Netflix yo
I'm tied free I don't trust my Ghost
Recon either watch these trailers man I
think that it looks phenomenal it's in
October all I'm saying is regardless of
how people feel it's almost like the
division our argument I had regardless
of how people feel the October it's
coming it's taking that space destiny
meaning you got a talk but what we go
and do oh you're telling me you might go
play another game you might might step
no no no no no I say understand but you
you sound excited though something else
maybe curat replace weird you want you
want someone you want some time to play
something else I I do not I do know it's
okay so you're just gonna leave you're
just gonna leave that thing that's just
like 10 out of 10 on fire over there
just leave it over there in the bushes
you're not gonna go grab it
listen I will play this video regardless
but here's the thing from a business
standpoint long as they get in front of
it if you're gonna bend a knee bend the
knee with pride Fred even honor you know
jump out and say hey with the new
structure I know what Activision you
guys used to you know September but
we're working on like you do tea party
statement but do you do a bond and
statement hold on that one out over here
there you go we've got the transcript
order
all right Luke Smith and from the camera
sir guard a Guardians out there in the
world please take pity on us while we
take this breather go play your other
games get your yes and then come back
and we're going to show you how it's
really done in your life baby aim to me
why why you see it bend the knee that's
really not emphasis no that's it no it's
no oh it's no games
yes Zoe editor mobile games if you was
caught if they were confident myself
they're gonna drop a disabled boy lives
it boss not each other but they know Wow
I shouldn't say because we don't know
what what happens is what happens did
this is serious competition yeah it
would be crazy so again to me it's I
call it a retreat you retreat you just
like hold the line where you are let
people go do other stuff get done with
that and come back with side it's a
retreat you know why because they waste
drop sometimes Activision always made
them drop September dating say no did
they have a choice now they have you're
right they do have over to have a choice
and that's what I want to see what
happens they actually fought back at
Activision oh let's not act like Bungie
is completely complicity with everything
because remember we got rise of iron
when we're supposed to get destiny -
yeah but the timber still they had they
had to say something there so it was
another joke way we missed a Content
drop and then we had um like the spring
of daters yeah that trash they dropped
Luther gonna listen at the end of you
know no hold the license to bend the
knee retreat retweet the white walkers
are coming you see September the white
walkers out here we got Master Hunter
Borderlands October we got wild lands
November we got Call of Duty the white
walkers are coming which is Herman when
when does window things happen now
December
get out in front of it get out of front
of us a look yeah it's like I do 100
just like go public and be like hey this
is what we wanna do retreat we're gonna
retreat you guys have fun we I didn't
give us like a snippet give or do do
something cool give like show shorter
space Doritos to a sunblock right
neither everybody's a host please do
coming and on some whoa okay we can hold
the line go play something else then you
do your thing but you gotta get in front
of it do not not say anything that's the
key to cannot not say you have to say
something that's so in July or August
what you're saying is they come out and
say word not worth the live service will
maintain the game until December Oh
mommy see you know we got we've got a
treaty we've got a treaty man I should
go back about like for four weeks five
weeks so let's try to act right dodo try
act like you wanted we have a treaty
because the pole is on the key is
getting out in front of it just get out
in front of it don't watch anything what
it is but I wouldn't be mad if you
treated you you hold the line for a
comment either I'm not gonna I'm not I'm
not gonna get upset if I I still get a
comment but I understand this time this
is definitely that they breach the walls
the night King yours iam I'm just gonna
go ahead and move on good thing I'm just
gonna take take one up in the collar
here don't know oh no I'm in already
already got a victory right here longer
so but yeah there's so here's the
question so the wait you feel about this
raid coming the way they're setting up
the race and everything like that
we're on may 10th division twos raid oh
boy do you ever think when it comes out
and that it can't even hold a candle to
this thing no the canid st race I mean
okay matter physics but this is what
they keep waiting on this is what
they're waiting this is why they're
pushing it back otherwise why not just
really sit mm-hmm listen okay so is like
so I mean I'm trying to like see how
screwed are they like
I mean they've waited a long time at
this but we don't have a date okay let's
really in now you know I'm just saying
on the rate on the Ray
you're just like they don't have a date
yet I know friends that are like we got
well we got the a friend he put out the
statement but with title three the
update you know in second grade they
said operation dark hours the eighth
player raid coming in title update three
with also an ex when they made the hole
they jumped in front of the gear score
500 stuff so they they're coming out in
front and saying it's coming in tile
left a three if you are
check out that latest of state of the
game in developer update for May 8th
they did say it they did say it's coming
but here's the thing I don't even look
at division in that that space to be
honest like division right now their
plant base is extremely high they're
still doing only the hardcore is really
complaining in my opinion as far as when
this raid is coming you know saying they
haven't announced today but yeah it
sounds like it's gonna be a few days but
here's the thing the way that game is
structured they've they put it this way
this is a game that has not had a raid
before right they I'm not used to they
don't know what that is so yes you are
up you are a little frustrated that it's
not coming you know I'm saying you like
okay where is it where is it what I
think it's one of those students that
when these drops people are gonna you
know people are gonna be fine you know
I'm saying like I I don't think it's one
of these things where it's like oh my
god the player base is so frustrated
abandon ship you know this is not
happening people are regular normal
people still like myself like people
ain't even tier three there's a huge
chunk in that community that has not
it's just a hark with the loudest voices
so they've made did you see the update
what they said as far as the um how
they're gonna handle the gear squad
they're not my dear score for one yeah
yeah so they're not bumping up to 515
especially because that was gonna be
exclusively in the dark zone and two
things that I'm like good job for one to
take that crap out of the dark zone hate
that place Allah and I love how I read
the article down you're like oh no so
bad there's all not them I'm not like
alone in my thoughts the lake locking hi
crap in the dark zone you do not have
you force somebody to play it people
still don't like it
that sounds like okay if you work in a
bowl put some higher stuff now there's
two different arguments like bumping 500
515 to take all the stuff you've been
working on working on your builds and
I'm like 500 max and then you make 15
powerlevel score more just for unwind
bird that was gonna be useless and
that's one thing even when we go back to
destiny were like hey we are go from 700
to 750 outside of the raid being this
like it's annoying that rates but you're
like oh it's like maths the point where
it's like infusion core is like that's
the thing is like even division doesn't
have that like even if you do have to go
500 5 15 you would be getting new drops
that's the problem once you brush before
you wouldn't be trying to infuse it but
either way it's just like just a little
bump at that point you're like well yeah
so they're smart to listen they're about
the gear score and to not putting it in
the dark zone so all good things there I
think
arrey like that's that's a little ya
know that's that's huge for them next
late sit down and listen to be like this
is our plan community's pissed we're
gonna change our plan like that takes
some people that takes enough like in
touch this with your community be like
guys they're really not happy about this
how high up do you have out and somebody
likes it like some community manager
reading this first people in the forum's
like devs like check in there you'll
post and stuff finally going like how
high up do they have to crawl the bosses
be like guys don't change this we're
gonna piss them off and they listened I
was like how price like how you was not
worried about them like it's just what
you said yeah it is literally this is a
game that knows what it was like to be
dead right then literally came back like
the phoenix from the ashes in reinvent
itself in part - they are fine I am NOT
where they have been consistent I look
at the UM the users it's a the game
played they let day off more than fine
like I bet they have none where about
yes people have those drives for the
little things with I mean on little
things it is a big thing but people have
that great weight I feel like we talk
about it every last word but if I say at
the end of the day when it drops and
it's done right they're gonna be fine
I'm not worried about it you don't say
so this is good this is really good I
really like them holding that line cuz
like you said it becomes a score right
and then it's just like you're gonna go
crazy and then like you said that
don't change we're changing that loop
and then you're also gonna drop an
exotic weapon during that period good
stuff man III am no problem they are in
pocket as far as I'm sir
yeah I was like I was just impressed
they'll listen that's kind of a big
thing I mean that's one of those that I
mean some people are just like hell or
high water this stuff's gonna happen
it's for one it means your game has
actually enough flexibility to change
snot like hey we've got this coming
here's this patch the gear score is
gonna change raids gonna come week later
they have enough flexibility in their
engine in their development cycle and
things like that to be able to roll with
that type of change or if that's not
even as easy as it would be for them to
just sit there and say we can't do this
it's not the right call whatever time it
takes fix it and that's like yeah it
could be even like double dev time to
not bump it up or figure out what they
need to do what they still listened and
made that call so I mean that is that is
an absolute I call for them and what
they should do so my my more thing is
just getting to when the raid comes out
if season of opulence actually does like
crush there's depending on the time
those will be compared of course I was
like and then it's and it's like and it
sucks because this is I can't even count
how many raids we've been through and d1
and d2 a lot this is their first real
one and it's like and you've always got
learning experiences that change from
one to another and sadly vault of glass
for destiny what was their first raid
they did they did well with that one
like people still love that one so it's
like I would be I will just be curious
to watch how that one rolls I don't know
what to expect here's the thing I think
we have to be careful this is I noticed
where you're going with it and I
understand the thought process but we
have to be careful with comparing
divisions raid to a destiny only in a
sense that I don't think raid is a core
part of their experience this is
something that they are trying that
they're gonna see what happens right you
know if put it put it this way if the
division rate is average to below
average I still don't think it destroys
their community so this I think it would
be one of those things like okay we'll
take feedback you guys don't like this
we want that and then they'll do
whatever like I don't even look at that
like it's not no come
to me it's not I hate to be
disrespectful there was a vein that
really don't right
there's nothing [ __ ] outside of you
know space monsters dropping down into
the you know what's really gonna happen
in the vision rate that you're gonna be
like oh my god you know they like it fun
it could be funny could be enjoyable
yeah come clear rooms and breaching and
do it up it's just a different space and
and it's nothing gonna compare to a
world's first when we see an OP Oryx
standing up in that giant final room
like this DISA iconic moments like you
remember when before this guy right like
oh my god get the so I didn't you know
one person had the heroic moment
its guy yeah remember I was the damn
runner to I always like again it I don't
even it's like you guys play on the
kiddie playground over there which I
doing is cute
you don't say as far as trying to get
where we are but what we do is what we
do we're the raid guys we know what this
is now what they do is say okay you guys
are a guy but guess what we got the best
balance we got the most moves we got mid
max we got hardcore sensibilities that
you guys don't have you said I'm saying
so to me it's like they playing in their
space and they're just battling for
player base on here and there but let's
be honest vision is still up here as far
as player base as far as engagement
destiny is trying to get us back with
stuff like I outbreak crime and you know
I'm saying now we're getting hearing
about opulence and I'm saying but at the
end of the day as much as I'm a destiny
fan I have to admit division is here as
far as engagement what gamers are as a
whole or playing yeah it's universally
right now by different groups people are
back playing divisions so dusty still
has its work cut out for it to get
everything that know yeah that's why I
wanted to kind of bring this topic up is
because you've got to two different
communities some mini that overlap like
many people that cross that Venn diagram
sit in the middle and you've got people
playing both and it's this kind of a
point to where it'll be interesting to
see like you know some of the people
that cover both see what they say about
each one is
they come out and just kind of follow
the next the next month should be
interesting no I got to get us in all
the right training ship you all right
take care of that you're good bro you
told my job he throwing Ghost Recon
shade because he's such a division
fanboy and I understand but here's the
thing you have to admit Peter I'm giving
a sneak preview of what I'm gonna talk
about on IOP on Sunday you have to admit
that Ubisoft which is you know I'm
saying developing you know saying this
game publishing this game this this
could backfire what if Ghost Recon is
amazing and it's doing all these things
it's literally in the same kind of a
realistic tactical space as division so
that's all I'm saying you need to be
concerned if you're a division fan that
hey this game is dropping in October who
knows what I know did the vision you
would think has their content update
spread accordingly but it's kind of
weird to me out you know what it kind of
got a little vibes it's not a direct
comparison but it's giving me ghost
recon it's gonna fit you I hate her
anyway it's giving me fields of
titanfall and battlefield melody a did
that yeah number one and we were like
titanfall 2 and battlefield would be
like yeah of course but it's just like
I'm just saying I don't necessarily put
it this way Ghost Recon in my opinion
didn't need to come out this year as far
as I'm concerned it was fine I know they
gonna make the money this another has a
point though it's still gonna be a co-op
campaign start to finish it's not a
looter shooter with a replayability
right in cream and grinding and all that
stuff so you guys you have different
pieces to it right but here's the dick
remember the same way we're saying that
the same way we saying this about
borderland
what les is saying I said that it's
looters shoot in a sense that boy lanes
gonna have a new game plus new game plus
plus there's all those different things
there's still
replayability to it you're not gonna
level up your character in Ghost Recon
true they're saying is Crafton and
they're saying is raid that I was
shocked by that to be honest I didn't
think that would even though that
verbage even comes in
we got to be honest yeah so I'm curious
to see what happens later dramatic
shutout brother um you know at the end
it's just interesting to me that they
would put this out not seeing it super
close to division cuz division came out
so early it just seems to be playing in
the same space I'm just a little
concerned with that you know with them
dropping that game night I felt like oh
she could've came out next year in five
but that's just me that's just me
we'll see I mean honestly it's just one
of those like it's that point where it
could be a fun game and it's gonna be
far enough from Division they probably
make sure they don't time it with like
hey here's act you know act 2 or act 3
or whatever their seasons are gonna be
they're gonna separate those I would
feel for sure but I don't think one is
gonna step on the others toes that much
so here's my question Division fans and
smell a check when she's making great
points and I'm saying shout to sinister
he loves all those time play there's but
I love these games yeah like why do when
does division then drop their rope Matt
like what's the roadmap for their
expansion right like when do they drop
it cuz right now we're coming up on you
know May June when's the next when's the
next big title update right you gotta be
cognizant of everything that's coming
they got a deal if we're talking about
destiny there you gotta worry about
Borderlands day you gotta worry about
Monster Hunter you gotta worry about you
know Ghost Recon Call of Duty where do
they fit now September they're gonna
drop out of content thing in September
what are you gonna drop I'll probably do
there's like Jill like mid July right
Danny I would bet because they've I mean
yeah however you go I mean they had
three different acts or whatever for
their specializations stuff like that in
a plan they're definitely not gonna
because we're March April May unless
they just drop in the middle of June
which seems kind of bad for a news cycle
they're probably gonna be July so I mean
they're you're already gonna be off on a
cycle that's gonna point they're not
gonna be on that annual cycle they're
not even gonna hold to that but here's
the date that you now you answer on my
point which is fantastic which is
because this rate keeps getting delayed
right right you can't tell me that this
was in the playbook right wait if they
had a playbook of how ideally things
were supposed to go this Ray was
supposed to been out so the
fans I think you guys need to be
concerned as well like it you guys are
off-kilter as far as release content and
I'm saying so now you gotta work around
you gotta be careful in opulence as much
you know like the elf eye beliefs is
what we think is gonna be and we're
getting this excited about a great prime
right and if opulence is what we think
it's gonna be divisions stay away cuz
you know how to destiny community guess
we all bun you gotta do a drop a hot
trailer callous talking that talk fat
from strength drinking out of some flask
looking like this or you got do a drink
from a flash looking like this give us
some hot exacts from great our
activities you know that thing is just
get that's just admitting you into
medieval times yeah you know what
My lordy lordy got birthday at me but um
yeah so that's pretty much what it is so
like I say division community don't get
too cocky all right you guys got some
potholes you got over - I'm done renting
uh so I wanted to let you get on the
road soon let you open you up and just
let you go I'm not a division expert by
any stretch I haven't played it that
much like I need to get back on playing
with my brother some but stuff like this
keeps happening with like outbreaks I've
been a little preoccupied
so mommy silver Belle yeah turned upside
down that's pretty much what it looks
like he's playing that like ball in a
cup
he's just playing ball in a cup with
that I'm gonna call mom one water out of
this flip oh yeah
I'm actually you might want to watch
that first it could be done because it's
been sitting up there getting no use not
even behind you on like a pedestal on
camera it's just no one knows it's there
and so you pull it out that sounds
really bad by the way don't pull it out
oh come on you guys have ever seen the
other side of me I hope it really clean
on my chest
oh that's real life I'm kind of dirty so
nothing terrible but honestly that's
like that's like I will be curious to
see what happens with division to trade
honestly just I'm curious what they do
to make it unique because they have a
very specific style they have the
military they have the cover they have
all those pieces in there and I just
want to see what they do with it if they
can be creative enough with the realism
space that they're in to make something
like as you said split off and do two
different sides and be like hey if we're
talking in this like Dischord chat and
be like okay we've got a hit switch one
into at the same time go we hit three
and four at the same time go
okay these doors are all open okay rush
in so which I mean I can see them doing
something that's kind of cool um I'm
just curious to see what it looks like
in their eyes more than anything it's
just a curiosity of mine at this point
curious as well we just got I'm telling
y'all as destiny fans keep expectations
in check oh I know that's what I'm
saying I'm I'm not setting them high for
this one I just want to see what it
actually looks like be very curious
lutely par 5 it has been a long time
since I've seen you in this job although
some how you doing sir is facing to need
some new face I know you have it a good
chat today thank you all absolutely
thank you I owe punch Apple coming over
Gracie is gracing my chat I do stream a
lot feel free to come over more often
than once a week appreciate it yes I
know I need a show about face I've been
I've been in the secret actually I
should play with shadows creep we got
some PvP ended nice nice
but yeah I mean division twos got an
interesting roadmap ahead we've got a
lot of questions for destiny and then
sadly our other topic of at least in the
literature world until we get a little
more Borderlands to test out I mean
people were saying like you know the
major developers for anthem is what I'm
going to talk about now for just about
two minutes anthem had like a lot of
developers leave they moved on to Dragon
Age for some of them did but potentially
like you know the main piece the game is
out they've turned it over to the live
service team so they are still gonna
support this thing but honestly at this
point as we've said before it feels like
Anthony's just like go back make their
game and then re-release it with like a
name and expansion a free content update
something Luke 2.0 is what they need so
I was like I just
wanted to touch on anthem just to say go
for it it's a shame because I honestly
haven't logged in ages
I really haven't known I've been busy
it's like and I never even like maxed
out there's the new stronghold to try
but so much is just like so much is more
appealing to me to a game that I'm like
I'll go back when it actually kind of
matters yeah bro I mean it just kind of
hurts because like in high in my head
it's mmm it is a fun fun as hell concept
I love the way those suits feel but
there's you see it's yeah it's like
anthem it's like it's not wrong but for
now instead like this and it washes out
match working issues
that's really bad yeah that is really
bad well last time you jumped in it was
it was that bad as far as like okay no I
haven't touched it so bad I've heard
about max making issues I haven't done
it when you hear about that type of
issue though
yeah that's literally like anthem needs
a no man's sky Division one needs a like
rebranding we're back with another name
and we got stuff to do like didn't have
to yeah I'm very worried very well I'm
just this is even bigger than anthem now
I mean you know this is by where this is
now I'd hate to say it I mean I want to
call an time a flop with it one MPD but
by EA standards they've already you know
what they did E
they pulled an Activision know when
Activision trying to talk slick the
Bungie it was like forsaken did not meet
our expectations it was not up to snuff
remember that now you need your gobbler
what are you doing they bought that when
they pulled that in and they literally
just got on that early say through
anthem all the way under the bus so at
the end of the day vagabond oh don't get
too excited about Dragon Age before I've
got some behind the scene things I'm
hearing that I do not like I cannot
disclose just yet but put it this way
there's one thing I everyone has sorted
did say that's public sphere and they
were just like they somebody said it's
anthem with dragons
no no fam
so I love dragons II inquisition um you
know this might not be the same by a way
that we used to and the problem right
now is this is now flop number two
according to EA not saying it's a
financial flop but according to EA way
ahead and drumming in this drama to
harbor the phasers off shadow number
that that was that it was in trouble was
a mean let's be very you know real about
it was a mean people would be exec yeah
but the eyes are doing all it yeah just
like these eyes are doing all that
that was a drama at Lord's yes yes so
that you know and um not say freewheelin
do that we ain't gone disrespecting cuz
this Inquisition was really good one
game of the year that yen I know I've
never played it but I have heard other
people actually say like Inquisition was
like game of the year but they're like
did it really need to be though I've
heard people say that felt like I have
no idea I'm literally just saying other
things I've heard so it's like I don't
have a point of our enclosed issue this
fan okay alright we gonna do day but at
the end of the day all say and said
where it's not alone no I agree I mean
maybe some people there is some chirps
but it was overall recognized in any one
the game was game of the year but we you
know it is what it is you know some
people didn't like it you know I get it
maybe the hardcore Dragon Age guys you
know if they comparing series fine but
the masses enjoy the game
anyway two flops in a row and um now I
want to Dragon Age 4 and here's the real
thing when people say we're gonna still
support the game this is the live team
now of people we don't know working on
answer we got we got to be realistic you
know saying what what's really going to
happen so my hope I'm still open you
know I'm still hoping they have that I
just need like like a ABBA deal said
they need a no man's sky type moment
take a couple months really grind out
you know they've had a good update
recently with doing stuff not having to
go to for Tarsus you know I'm saying we
need more story content added we need
some cataclysms we need all that going
on
you just hope this thing turn around
because like he said still nothing to
this day Beach jump in and at you Evelyn
and just taking off right oh man dude it
felt so good the first time you and it's
like they nailed that so so well in
whatever there's a short window flying
was in and out and in and out and all
that stuff and it was like all of a
sudden you're just like how does this
feel so it just felt natural it's like
it was like for me I was on PC says like
space to jump space to fly it I was just
like oh I was like damn it that feels
awesome
like they they had their wait like the
interceptors mainly jumping around being
absolutely ninja crazy which is probably
one of the reasons I even had more fun
because I wasn't as gun based which is
one of the reasons I think I probably
have enjoyed it more than some because I
wasn't as gun dependent pending yes you
ladies dependent yeah those abilities
and it was jumping and moving all around
it felt absolutely crazy I thought I was
gonna make my stream throw up for motion
sickness like I mean that part was fun
but like yeah there just wasn't there
was it was a very very shallow of a game
like the surface the framework was there
yeah but they base they basically just
put the frame up for a house and like
cool the mechanics of how you move
around are they're awesome
what else he got you know and it was and
that's they just need to go build a game
now they gotta build a game again just
like you said my moment is literally
taking off flying doing my trial
whatever and then hover stationary shoot
ability you know I'm saying calm down
mainly like just that basic gameplay
mechanic was amazing to me so um yeah
you know you just hope that they really
can can just dig deep keep pushing
reinvent itself and come back reborn and
honestly I think next generation
consoles would be the way to do it
because I played on console home it's
just too ambitious a game for Korea
that's a lot you ask yeah it's a CPU
that's out on console right now but the
next generation PlayStation the next
generation Xbox you know you're using a
nominee gonna use the beta better GPUs
you know we're gonna see the bigger one
like the big eight course oh guys give
me that zen-like back
supposedly what's gonna go in peace PS 5
and probably my new builder AMD it's
like what's probably going on both of
those whatever level for Xbox for both
of them especially the upper one it's
not even know yet it's not danced out
for me I can't go play it and put on my
system yet dude like that's kind of
impressive to a point that there I feel
like they're not going to be as far
behind I feel like when the consoles
have come out at least this one it was
fairly far behind mm-hmm we never stop
yeah it's like it feels like it's gonna
be now graphics if it's knobby which is
not gonna be I forget what's called
after that I can't remember but Navi is
gonna be there's one beyond Navi for AMD
I mean nabis not out and it's supposed
to launch but I feel like there's one
beyond it but it's still it's like
relatively current stuff now which is
gonna give them and again that's the big
difference to is like I mean whatever
you hear when you take a system like a
computer you still gotta run an
operating system you so I've gotta run
all this other stuff dedicated gaming
systems with similar specs are gonna be
able to knock like a different level of
stuff out that's YP and that's why you
learn efficiency they learn how to use
the systems that's why the last episodes
ps3 The Last of Us on ps3 look freaky
and amazing and you're absolutely how
the hell did you pull that out of the
system exactly and then it's like okay
so it's like they're getting to a point
where you put like my hardware in a
dedicated gaming rig it's like holy crap
like exactly then you talk about
customization you took my dedicated
combination optimization on a console
level which will be like I said these
newer CPU GPUs that are gonna be it's
gonna be right there at the PC space and
they're talking on Rachel a ray tracing
we don't know it was gonna be on a
hardware level that we're asking a lot
but whatever even the implementation of
you know I mean they next generation
consoles gonna be fine and to me and
don't reborn in that space with some
type of huge you know content no mask I
type a Content update or division type
it could be you know could really
rebirth kind of nice and I would like to
see that that's what I would love in a
perfect world love to see that ya know
for sure
lots of stuff so I mean as the future of
gaming goes that continues
be bright and it's a good place to be a
gamer have fun there was a question on
Twitter though and I'll read you my
answer cuz I doubt you actually saw it
so I wanted to ask a quick random
question so you had like whatever reason
I want to throw anything bad at the
universe but you know you could sit like
you know sit and just play a late play
games the other one another play through
through them or you want to finish them
because you haven't take like a couple
months what would you just like and this
is just where we'll wrap this thing up
just out of curiosity like old games you
missed games you want to play through
again just give me a list of stuff that
you're like if I had time no obligations
no way of work trying to keep up with
destiny and trying to do anything of
that or the other what's your like
what's your backlog or your replay log
that you'd be like what's some stuff I
want to hit or I have a never Wow and
now this consists of any things I'd give
a damn Oh anything yeah just like quick
stuff that pops your head though just
give me like you know five six seven
that just like pop and be like what have
you not played what would you want to go
back to her again after any whatever
like my Sony single-player library I got
is so much stuff I got I got got a war
on a finished
I got Spidey I got Detroit I love
Detroit like must get bro I love those
Sony single-player games and it's just
like it's just so hard for me to just
and then people like hey I just want you
to jump in and help me do this partner
rate real quick hey you know I just want
you to jump in and it'll be quick and
then the next do you know that's eight
hours do not disturb on your phone go
invisible mode you gotta be like man
what happened dude I want to play game
named Lugh there's um there's another
game it's I've had to develop and I
really like it's called Kingdom Come
deliverance I love it's like a hardcore
Skyrim
mm-hmm oh man I love that game mmm
trying to get maybe two more mice which
lag hey I got some grace which games man
some really good switch games I want to
get to all this is getting called the
messenger like 2d platformer
Metroidvania carnist I love Metroidvania
kind of stuff nice domme party the last
one
actually um with what you call it
dropping arm on Xbox I mean obviously
with what you could with who
it kind of make me one play wildlands
I'll give it a daddy what played a split
itself
I wish myself an a head like a DLC
component to that and um you know get
that in and snuggles give me crap yeah
of course the vision I want to be able
to still rock conjunction on a single of
destiny it's so much man it is really so
that's the problem with loving looter
shooters it's a selfish relationship
she's just selfish man that's what
you're tired but you when uh my list was
I never finished horizon zero dawn mm
never finished breath of the wild all
brought to the what there's another one
say I'm like it's going uh I didn't make
it a good way through Odyssey actually I
did play that pretty solid after playing
SEC here I want to play blood-borne
again mmm now me I'm gonna get crap for
this forever and I still have to do it
at some point
Mass Effect one through three it's still
gotta happen you never touched him ever
so I but I've never been really that
spoiled on it either so I'm like this
age as I know I didn't age well but I
heard late their ups and downs the one
and two both so yeah no no no to to lean
on Khosla whoever said told you that
Miss a giving misinformation on well no
like not ups and downs like there were
different things like some people like
either combat or abilities and one may
know it's like yeah there were like just
differences between the two that some
were as I said like liked and disliked
less more but for me at some point the
one that I still want to do that I
haven't done and it's kind of a fear of
nostalgia of not touching it
mm-hmm-hmm is Chrono Trigger that's your
baby
that is my baby and I'm afraid to go
play I want to play it again I've only
heard it like it's still on everybody's
lists like it's eating there speaking of
babies and aunts feels really I would
love to play that again - yeah
what do you joke about Final Fantasy 7
trip I'll play that because that is
reimagined because that we make the 15
engine with seven basically is what they
finally had to do 7 is mmm yeah it's
crazy man salute ba ba ba yah up says
a couch in army mass spec one ya met bro
amazing amazing game so many good so
many good games exist to dab back into
good question so that's why was like it
came up I saw it and I was like seemed
like a good one
so and that's one of those it's like
it's hard sometimes and that's why those
times when it's like content may be a
little slower on the channel or whatever
it's like and then it's like I played
through SEC arel absolute blast almost
want to go play it again but then I'm
like then this will come out then you
got opulence and that's the that's those
times where I'm just like if bunchy is
like hey we're gonna work on this we'll
drop it in December it'd be like thank
God thank you couple minutes just so I
can have some freedom well that's yeah
but I mean you to be like oh man I got I
got a couple months I can actually go
play some of this other stuff like see
but y'all my problem is you like come
back I know me I mean what do you want
come back for destiny you just described
getting giddy about a damn quest much
less a game or an expanded right now
we're gonna come back probably it's just
that I like to focus on something you
know I like I'm not one thing at a time
guy my god I don't like to do six
different things and I'm like not
finishing anything like but I mean this
is good but I was like this is why I was
like it is good to focus on something
but the the break the departure the
change of pace sometimes makes you think
that you love that much when you take
that separation when you clear your head
space of whatever was there and you step
back in and you pull a trigger for the
first time again in destiny it does make
it feel that much better I know where
you're going with it but no that's why
I'm like that's why I'm okay with like
taking that couple weeks off to play
soccer and then I was like and that'll
still play destiny on Tuesdays and stuff
but those those focuses on something
else so I'm just not as hardcore have
been have been nice to just refresh and
be like it was perfect like played sec
hero been doing a little maintenance
worked on a couple and then this thing
came out I was like oh here goes me
grind another solo thing again so it's
like it's a nice like influx at that
point but it's like for me it's I I
enjoy the separation something like
chrono triggers not even like the same
game even it's just like let's just go
see how this feels in the memories and
see if it holds up are you agent I got
we just got yeah we got
an approach would you just won't like
when I play destiny or I'll play that
Luda shooter that I like especially
destiny it's one of those things that
there is no gunplay that compares to me
like when I get I know playing a lot of
other shooters that's why it's hard
that's why it's almost gonna be hard
depending I know people said Borderlands
3 was crispy ER in the shooting but it's
not like it's not gonna come on shooting
land it's less exactly I don't want to
disrespectful to anybody who loves but
like you say it's lit I know it it's the
same thing with about rage right and I'm
like yeah this is gonna come out ray and
I'm like it's cute that's what I mean
and that's the bit thing we do know as
well but sometimes those breaks win
they're working when Bungie needs time
to make something it's it's okay to go
like be like hey here's this thing
because when it does come back it still
knocks it out of the park so it's like
it makes you just be like yeah they're
still won and it's it makes you almost
solidify them more when you take a
separation you go play destiny or
division you work on your leveling up
and then you come back to destiny and
you're like one quest gets me this
excited game a Bungie you're still like
one of it like the best so it's like
it's it's really cool what Bungie is
capable of doing with for one with just
a video marketing whoever does those
just freakin clutch oh yeah it walking
is amazing yeah so those are always
awesome but it's I honestly think
sometimes for you it's like the point
where you do need some separation well I
don't know if you play huh I already got
my separation now you know what my
separation is the Nintendo switch oh
that's true you do that all the time
yeah dude that's awesome saying I'm fine
like when I'm home
they got my baby when I'm away I got
this plethora this library that I can
just indulge
oh you think I'm not playing I'm playing
all the games it's when I get home and
then someone and I'm blaming you because
you hooked me up with the hot rig right
he'll be good so now I'm just me in all
this glory right someone with nine-nine
progress
yeah he talked about take a break you
know buddy gave me the greatest version
of my drug like take a break go away
no I'm loving this and I'm playing it
with this having a boss yeah that's what
you're doing wrong now they can't mess
with me too I'm killing it out here I'll
kill it all control master race it it
was me take a break no feely laughing no
it's been fun this morning thank you
chap for being awesome you guys have
been great a little nostalgia trip there
and that's one of those like I was
wonderful icon streams if I like if I
set aside be like alright Wednesday
night so I'm gonna play through a Chrono
Trigger and it's like but it's like I
gotta find the time cuz I honestly would
have to truly set a date yeah because
I'm like you'll moans like well I could
be right now I need to figure out what I
want to work on for like titles and
stuff like that so it's just one of
those but if I truly want to do
something like that it just got to be
like alright Wednesday nights dreams are
gonna be current or or Wednesday night
streams are gonna be working through my
backlog of like I'm gonna finish her
eyes and I'm gonna beat the 'final
Valkyrie in God of War like all those
things so there's certain pieces in
there that I kind of feel like I want to
do that if I could get a consistent
schedule so it's been it always makes
you think but yeah destiny is one of
those things that makes it hard to do
that so in a good way it's an amazing
good way I think we will wrap it up here
so thank you guys all for hanging out in
chats may actually see about raiding a
group so if you guys want to hang out
we'll see if we can actually send you
guys over to somebody in the Destiny
world so we'll see if I can find
somebody here who's playing and having
fun having a good time a little morning
juice yeah you guys are all awesome so
thank you I'll send you guys off
but for this podcast I think that's
pretty much what we got covered so
kognito
if you want to wrap up tell them where
you're at yeah at Lourdes kind of a
don't know him by now know at low
incognito on twitter and at a little
podcast on twitter every sunday on
podcast 1 p.m.
I don't know podcast YouTube we actually
have a changing in guest yes I don't
know who my guests gonna be yeah we had
a last-minute cancellation so we'll
figure it out but please check us out
we're gonna talk about all the latest in
gaming and of course all the core
consoles or fun or
cash loads in Rome and of course get
lords of gaming that net for your gaming
news boy it has a cool little article up
about what's going on with this rage
crown of sorrow you know some thoughts
about this whole process so check that
out but um yeah man that's it man thanks
for having this was fantastic
what's going on what you make yeah I'll
probably be doing some streams I've got
kind of busy tomorrow so Sunday or
Saturday I won't be doing too much got a
scene detective Pikachu this weekend so
I mean gotta get in there and see that I
think it's just gonna be fun goofy or it
is good to be cell that signaling sonic
not not touching that one today yeah you
guys know where to find me it's twitch
and twitter youtube all the good things
on Yvonne chest I've been hovering right
under 34,000 sub so you guys know a few
people can you guys like help bump me up
over that I feel like I'm like bumping
against the ceiling so if you guys want
to send a reai a sub over to my youtube
channel that would be appreciated but
you guys can finally right here a lot
lately i've been streaming quite a bit
and i'll be working on basically
probably just bashing my head against
that solo practice so i want to sell
those ear our it's gonna have to happen
at some point so thank you guys very
much have an awesome one and for us here
on the podcast that is the last word